Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, das Projekt von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove. Und ja, nach einer kleineren Pause machen wir hier wieder weiter mit neuen Themen. Und nachdem ja die letzte Sendung schon eine Überraschung dahingehend war, dass wir ja mal live auf der Bühne waren und dort auch inhaltlich mal einen ganz anderen Blick entwickelt haben, nämlich mir so einerseits in die Vergangenheit geschaut haben und auch den Vergleich herangezogen haben mit was hat die Science-Fiction vorher gesagt, was hat die Raumfahrt im Zuge dessen dann auch eingelöst und vielleicht auch gebracht, was selbst den Science-Fiction Autoren noch nicht so nahe lag. Jetzt wollen wir in gewisser Hinsicht in dieser Folge sogar ein ähnliches und weiterführendes Thema aufgreifen, was auch tatsächlich in Raumzeit 53 kurz anklang. Heute soll es nämlich gehen um eine Vision, ein Konzept für die Zukunft, wo noch viele Fragezeichen auf dem Papier stehen. Und dazu begrüße ich erst mal Markus Landgraf. Hallo Markus, wir wollen reden über den Space Elevator.
Hallo Tim.
Ja, du warst auch schon mal da. Du bist jetzt tatsächlich der erste Gast, der hier zweimal auftaucht. Bisher ist es immer gelungen, uns noch was Neues einfallen zu lassen.
Ja, mich kann man nicht ganz vermeiden manchmal.
Ja, offensichtlich. Das ist auch gut so. Wir haben tatsächlich in der zweiten Folge von Raumzeit miteinander gesprochen und da über dein Haus und Hof-Thema Missionsplanung. Wie geht man also Missionen frühzeitig überhaupt an, um mal sich überhaupt auszudenken, wo muss man denn irgendwas hinschließen, damit es dann auch da ankommt, wo man gerne möchte, dass es ankommt. Sehr interessante Folge auf jeden Fall, kann ich jedem, der soweit noch nicht zurückgeblättert hat, auch noch mal nahelegend da reinzuhören. Aber wie schon angedeutet, jetzt geht es ja um was anderes. Jetzt geht es nämlich um den Fahrstuhl.
Richtig.
Ja, das ist ja eigentlich gar nicht dein Thema. Also wie schon gesagt, dein Thema ist ja eigentlich Missionsplanung. Wir sind gerade in Darmstadt natürlich wieder beim ESOC. Und du arbeitest hier in der Missionsplanung, bist in viele Projekte eingebunden, wahrscheinlich auch viele immer parallel. Insofern gut, dass wir noch einen Termin gefunden haben. Ja, aber was hat es denn nun auf sich mit diesem Thema Space Elevator, Space Lift, Weltraum, Fahrstuhl, viele Namen kleiden das Konzept aus.
Warum beschäftigst du dich vor allem damit?
Also prinzipiell ist es ja so, dass Dynamik die Lehre der Bewegung ist und unser technischer Hintergrund ist, der dynamische Systeme zu analysieren. Das ist unser Werkzeugkasten, mit dem berechnen wir zum Beispiel die Flugbahn von Gaia. Da gibt es dann dynamische Modelle, da in diesen Modellen kommt dann die Schwerkraft von Erde, Sonne, Mond drin vor. Und in denen berechnen wir diese Bahn. Es ist natürlich so, dass man auch als Ingenieur und Wissenschaftler so ein bisschen wie der Bodybuilder ist, der auch mal seine Muskeln stehlen will, die nicht jeden Tag benutzt werden. Und man sucht eigentlich eine Beschäftigung auch, um die Infrastruktur, den Werkzeugkasten, den man hat, einzusetzen auf anderen verwandten Gebieten. Auch so ein bisschen um die kleinen grauen Zellen da noch ein bisschen mal zu trainieren. Und da ist die Beschäftigung mit dem Space Elevator eine ganz interessante, weil da tauchen ähnliche Probleme auf, wie in der normalen Missionsanalyse auch, aber auch sehr verschiedene Missionen, weil plötzlich da Makroskope, sehr großes System auftritt, das auch verschiedene Schwingungszustände hat und so weiter. Und da kann man einfach viel lernen bei, durch die Beschäftigung mit dem Space Elevator. Da kann man viele neue Methoden ausprobieren, neue Aspekte auch in der klassischen Missionsanalyse entdecken. Und der andere Aspekt ist, der mich auch so ein bisschen zum Elevator getrieben hat, ist die recht große Frustration, die man so als Missionsanalytiker mit sich rumträgt, dass es da einen Flaschenhals in der Raumfahrt gibt. In der Flaschenhals heißt es Raketenstart. Wir können tolle Missionen machen im Weltraum. Also alles, was sich Science-Fiction-Autor erdacht haben, könnten wir heute eigentlich schon umsetzen, wenn wir als Anfangszustand eine Infrastruktur im Weltraum hätten, im Erdorbit oder in der Erdnähe. Aber dieser Flaschenhals von der Erdoberfläche hochzukommen, der ruiniert diese ganzen Möglichkeiten, die wir eigentlich haben. Man könnte ja, ein schönes Beispiel ist so ein Pendel-Vehikel zwischen Mars und Erde. Kann man durchrechnen. Das ist zwei, drei, DIN A4-Seiten vollgeschrieben. Welche Anforderungen dafür man braucht. Das kann man mit heutiger Technologie bauen. Das ist noch nicht mal teuer. Problem ist, dass man das Ding, damit es einen Pendelbetrieb zwischen Erde und Mars geben kann, natürlich erst mal ein großes Vehikel von der Erdoberfläche starten muss, weil wir sind auf der Erdoberfläche. Jedes Kilogramm von der Erdoberfläche gestartet, kostet in der Größenordnung, je nachdem wohin man startet, zwischen 20 und 100.000 Euro.
Genau, denn das Problem ist, man muss es ja auch mal benennen, die Schwerkraft, die ja oft gescholten wird. Man kann schon froh sein, dass es sie gibt, weil sonst gäbe es uns wahrscheinlich so gar nicht. Zumindest nicht in der Form. Richtig. Aber das ist ja immer das Problem. Man muss überhaupt erst mal so viel Energie reinstecken in die ganze Geschichte, um die benötigte Masse überhaupt erst mal vom Planeten weg zu bekommen.
Und jetzt gibt es ein sehr interessantes Detail hier. Die Energie ist gar nicht so brutal. Das sind so ein paar Megawattstunden pro Kilogramm. Megawattstunde kauft man heute für, na ja, nach der Energiewende ist es ein bisschen mehr geworden. 30 Cent, keine Ahnung, weiß ich im Moment nicht auswendig. 30 Cent, das heißt mal 1000, da sind wir bei 300 Euro pro Kilogramm. Ist erst mal nicht viel. Es ist nicht 20.000 Euro. Woher kommen diese 20.000 Euro? Die kommen nicht von der Energie, die wir brauchen, sondern vom Impuls. Der Impuls, den man braucht, also einen Impuls, berechnet als massimal Geschwindigkeit. Das ist das Blöde. Im Weltraum kann ich mich nirgendswo dran abstoßen. Ich kann zum Beispiel hier mit einem Flugzeug, das hat Turbinen, das stößt die Luft nach hinten und treibt sich so voran. Das Auto hat seine Räder, drückt die Straße nach hinten, deswegen fährt das Auto nach vorne. Im Weltraum muss man das machen, indem man hinten eine Masse rausstößt. Das Blöde daran ist, wenn ich eine Nutzlast habe, muss ich Treibstoff haben, den ich nach hinten rausstoße. Das Dumme ist, ich muss diesen Treibstoff auch mitnehmen am Anfang. Das heißt, ich brauche mehr Treibstoff, um diese Kombination aus Treibstoff und Nutzlast nach oben zu bringen. Noch mehr Treibstoff bedeutet wieder mehr Treibstoff. Das ist eine Kette, die Gott sei Dank konvergiert, aber an einem Punkt, wo es sehr, sehr viel Treibstoff braucht. Das heißt typischerweise für unsere Ariane 5, die startet 10 Tonnen, wenn die auf der Startrahmen steht, wiegt die 700 Tonnen. Und dann ist es natürlich klar, wenn ich so ein 700-Tonnen-Vehikel bauen muss, um 10 Tonnen zu starten, dass sich dann immense Kosten aufsummieren. Und das ist dieses interessante...
700 Tonnen, um 10 Tonnen hochzukriegen.
Ja, das ist einfach erstaunlich. Und das ist dieses interessante physikalische Detail, das einem eigentlich meistens durch die Finger schlüpft, wenn man die dynamischen Hintergründe nicht kennt. Das, was Weltraumfahrt relativ teuer macht, ist die Notwendigkeit, den Impuls aufzubringen. Und der Vater dieses Gedankens ist Konstantin Zilkowski, wer den mal auf dem Wiki nachgucken will.
Ja, der schon in Russland früh die Grundlagen gelegt hat für die moderne Raumfahrt, im Prinzip sehr viel vorweggenommen hat und auch rechtbar halten hat mit all dem, was er so ausgerechnet hat.
Genau, von dem hören wir heute bestimmt auch mal.
Ja, von dem haben wir auch schon in der letzten Folge ein bisschen was gehört. Das heißt, das Problem ist, man braucht viel Energie, man braucht viel, also man, Impuls, ich würde jetzt mal das Wort Impuls so beschreiben, man muss diese Energie vor allem in sehr kurzer Zeit aufbringen. Oder wie kann man das sich am besten vorstellen, die Problematik?
Es gibt ein schönes deutsches Wort dafür, das nennt man Stützmasse bei einer Rakete. Aus Deutschland die alten Raketenbauer, die sagten dazu Stützmasse. Also Impuls ist eigentlich etwas, oder Impulsübertrag ist etwas, wo ich mich dran abstütze. Also im Prinzip, wo ich mich wegdrücke. Dieses newtonsche Prinzip, Accio gleich Reaktion. Ich brauche eine Masse, die ich irgendwo wegdrücke, damit ich in die andere Richtung gehe. Und solange ich eine mechanische Verbindung zur Erdoberfläche habe, ist das kein Problem. Wie ein Auto, hat eben durch die Reifen mechanische Verbindung. Wenn ich das nicht habe, sprich ich bin in der Umlaufbahn, in der ISS, um die ISS auch nur um einen Meter pro Sekunde zu beschleunigen, brauche ich Ummengen an Treibstoff.
Weil da einfach nichts ist?
Da ist nichts, wo ich mich abdrücken kann. Ich muss also was rauswerfen. Das ist das Blöde da dran.
Okay, das heißt, das ist so ein bisschen, aber das Problem besteht sowohl auf der Erde als auch im All. Und im All kriegt man es ja in dem Sinne auch nicht weg. Also ich meine, in dem Moment, wo wir irgendwie weit wollen, müssen wir uns immer noch am Nichts abstützen. Richtig. Aber das heißt, wir reden ja jetzt quasi mit dem Space Elevator über eine Idee, wie man anders von der Erde wegkommt. Das löst also auch nur die Hälfte des Problems.
Es löst 80 Prozent des Problems. Es könnte sogar 100 Prozent. Wollen wir da gleich mal diesen Pfad runtergehen?
Naja, wir könnten zumindest mal genauer erklären, was ist jetzt eigentlich gemeint. Also Weltraumfahrstuhl als Alternative zum klassischen Raketenstart. Wo kommt diese Idee eigentlich her? Und wie lange wird die schon aktiv verfolgt?
Richtig. Also dann machen wir mal eine schöne Geschichte mit dem Konstantin Tsiolkovsky draus. Es war ein schöner Sommertag in 1895. Und Konstantin war damals zu Besuch in Paris auf der Weltausstellung. Und wer schon mal in Paris war, es gibt ein sehr sichtbares Zeichen dieser Weltausstellung, das ist der Eiffelturm. Der wurde damals eingeweiht.
Der wurde dafür gebaut. Und eigentlich dachte man auch, man baut den danach wieder ab.
Interessant wusste ich gar nicht. Auf jeden Fall, Konstantin steht da drunter. Und er war ja damals schon, hat in Richtung Weltraum gedacht und hat überlegt, das ist ja ein Riesenturm. Was würde eigentlich passieren, wenn man den immer weiterbauen? Wenn man den so hochbauen, dass man da hochklettern kann. Da würde ja irgendwann mal nicht nur die Erdschwerkraft immer kleiner werden, sondern auch noch die Zentrifugalkraft der Erdrotation, dazu keinen nach oben ziehen.
So, als ob man so ein Jojo um seinen Kopf herumschleudert.
Richtig, genau. Und dann hat er sich hingesetzt, wahrscheinlich im Pariser Café, auf einer Servette, eine kleine Rechnung gemacht, hat herausgefunden, wenn ich bei 35.000 Kilometer Höhe bin, da ist die Erdschwerkraft genau gleich der Zentrifugalkraft. Das heißt, ich bin schwerelos. Und er wusste, das ist gleichbedeutend damit, dass ich in einer Umlaufbahn bin. Das heißt, wenn ich einen Turm habe, der 36.000 Kilometer hoch ist, und ich klettere bis zu dessen Spitze, bin ich in einer Erdumlaufbahn. Ohne einen Tropfen Treibstoff.
Also man lässt dann sozusagen einfach los den Turm und fällt nicht mehr runter, weil man so weit von der Erde herumgeschleudert wird, dass man einfach gar nicht mehr fällt. Es hebt sich eigentlich auf.
Die Zentrifugalbeschleunigung hebt die Erdschwerkraft auf. Das ist übrigens das Gleiche, was auch mit den Satelliten auf niedrigeren Orbit passiert. Die ISS fällt ja nicht runter, weil die Erdschwerkraft und die Zentrifugalkraft sich aufheben. Das nennt man eine Umlaufbahn. Bei diesem Turm Prinzip ist es so, dass man die Umlaufbahn nicht erreicht, dadurch, dass man sehr schnell wird, sondern man erreicht sie dadurch, dass man sehr hochgeht. Das ist einfach ein anderes Prinzip. Und jetzt ist auch wieder dieser Rückstoßgedanke.
Die Geschwindigkeit hat man ja in gewisser Hinsicht ohnehin schon, weil sich die Erde ja die ganze Zeit dreht. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass man jetzt keine Geschwindigkeit hätte. Man merkt sie bloß in der Regel nicht, weil alles andere sich genauso schnell bewegt.
Und die Umlaufbahnen werden ja auch immer langsamer, je weiter ich rausgehe. Auf der anderen Seite werde ich, wenn ich auf so einem Turm bin, immer schneller, je weiter ich rausgehe. Und irgendwann mal trifft sich diese Umlaufbahngeschwindigkeit und meine Rotationsgeschwindigkeit hat denselben Wert. Und das ist auch genau dieser selbe Punkt bei 36.000 km. Und man kann das schön, wie gesagt, auf so einer sehr Werte mal ausrechnen. Und das war die Geschichte vom Konstantin Zilkowski. Und er hat das konkret auch aufgeschrieben und vorgeschlagen als Alternative zur Rakete.
Aber müsste das nicht eigentlich von der Idee her, man ist ja dann auch geosynchron sozusagen. Aber die geosynchronen Satelliten sind ja schon noch ein bisschen weiter draußen.
Die sind genau auf dieser Höhe.
Genau da.
Genau da. Das ist der geosynchrone, geostationäre. Um genau zu sein, muss man geostationär sein.
Das heißt, wenn man diesen Turm jetzt wirklich so bauen würde, dann könnte man auch direkt die Satelliten mit der Handtasche nach oben bringen und dann einfach mit dem Werkzeugschlüssel rangehen und wieder reparieren und nachtanken und so weiter. Total einfach. Nur, dass das halt nicht so einfach ist.
Richtig. Das ist nicht so einfach. Aber was es einfach macht...
Hat er denn auch ausgerechnet, was das Ungetümmel dann wiegen würde?
Nee, hat er ja nicht. Da gibt es auch eine lustige Geschichte. Hier ist wieder das, was ich vorhin gesagt habe. Dieser Turm überträgt den Impuls. Alles, was ich brauche, um da hochzuklettern, ist die Energie. Die ist nicht so hoch. Ich brauche die Energie. Den Impuls nimmt der Turm auf als feste Struktur und überträgt die auf die Erdoberfläche. So, und jetzt geht die Geschichte weiter. Es gab also damals tatsächlich diese beiden Möglichkeiten, Weltraum zu kommen, diesen Fahrstuhl oder diesen Turm und die Rakete. Was natürlich so am Ende des 19. und Anfang 20. Jahrhunderts war, natürlich so ein Turm nicht so interessant, weil man hat sehr militärisch gedacht. Und so eine Rakete war dann schon relevanter. Dementsprechend floss auch relativ viel Geld in die Entwicklung von Raketen, dann gerade auch im Zweiten Weltkrieg. Und was die Rakete irgendwie dann natürlich zu einem großen Erfolgskonzept machte. Man hat es mit der Rakete geschafft, auf dem Mond zu fliegen. Großartige Sache. Das war das Vehikel, um Dinge vor Ort zu bringen. Was man aus dem Auge verloren hat, ist der Grund, warum man eigentlich diese andere Alternative aus dem Auge verloren hatte. Sie war eben militärisch nicht so relevant. Und das heißt, erst nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg, um genau zu sein 1959, kam ein Landsmann von Konstantin auf die Idee, mal auszurechnen, wie schwer der Turm wäre. Das war der Juri Atsutanov, den kann man auch mal googeln. Der hat gesagt, der wird so schwer, dass die Erdkruste ihn nicht aufnehmen kann. Eine Erdkruste würde unter dem Gewicht dieses Turms im Erdboden versinken.
Wenn man ihn jetzt so bauen würde wie den Eiffelturm. Also wenn man sich den Eiffelturm mit einer größeren Basis vorstellen würde.
Das ist einfach, man braucht so viel Material.
Also hat er jetzt auch schon die konkrete Statik, die man so brauchen würde, da quasi mit berücksichtigt?
Ja, die Statik ist auch irgendwo an der Grenze. Da gibt es Grenzen der Statik, Grenzen des Materials, aber auch schon die Gesamtmasse, die man bräuchte. Wenn man das extra poliert, das ist so brutal. Da würde einfach die Erdkruste drunter kollabieren. Also würde der Turm gehen?
Mag immer versinken.
Richtig, einfach runter, zack, in den Erdmantel. Das ist sowieso undenkbar. Schade. Die Mengen an Stahl, die man bräuchte, existieren im Universum, glaube ich, gar nicht. Der Azuthanov hat aber eine Alternative. Er hat gesagt, warum machen wir das nicht so? Wir fliegen ein Satellit hoch und er hat einen Seil an Bord. Wir starten ihn mit einer Rakete. Der Satellit ist dann auf einem geostationierten Orbit. Bleibt also von der Oberfläche aus gesehen über einem Punkt stehen.
Das war ja zu dem Zeitpunkt dann auch schon ein erreichtes Ziel.
Ja, es war kurz vorher. Der erste geostationäre Satellit wurde gestartet in 1964 aus Anlass der Olympischen Spiele. Aber das Konzept war natürlich schon weit vorher bekannt.
Man war sich auch relativ sicher, dass man da schon irgendwann hinbekommen würde.
Richtig. Und Raketen gab es auch schon, dass man das starten konnte und so. Dann ist natürlich auch gleich ausgerechnet, wie groß die Spannung auf diesem Seil wäre. Und da ist auch ein Wert gekommen, der sehr, sehr hoch war.
Also Seil reden wir jetzt auch wirklich von so einem Hanfseil sozusagen.
Ja, Stahlseil.
Stahlseil.
Stahlseil. Und da gab es dann noch ein paar Jahre...
Das war wie schwer, sagtest du, müsste das sein?
Das war... also damals hatte er... Er hatte einfach ausgerechnet ein Stahlseil, das einen durchgängigen Durchmesser hat. Egal wie dick das ist, das wird immer reißen. Also ausgehend von Stahl. Dann kam aber...
Weil einfach sozusagen die Gesamtmenge an Material, die erforderlich ist, also die Gesamtmasse auf 35 Kilometer gestreckt einfach so schwer ist, so viel Pull erzeugt, dass es einfach die eigene Festigkeit übersteigt.
35.000 Kilometer.
Entschuldigung, 35.000 Kilometer.
Also das würde einfach unterm eigenen Gewicht abreißen. Es gibt nur einen Punkt an dem Seil, der wirklich schwerelos ist, das ist nämlich der obere Punkt da. Und man müsste obendrein auch noch ein Gegengewicht haben, weil im Endeffekt muss man natürlich dafür sorgen, dass der Schwerpunkt bei 35.000 Kilometer ist. Das heißt also, man hat da oberhalb von 35.000 Kilometern Gegengewicht.
Warum braucht man das Gegengewicht?
Das verstehe ich jetzt nicht. Im Endeffekt ist es so, dass der Fahrstuhl oder das Seil straff bleiben muss. Das geht natürlich nur, wenn ich einfach ein Seil habe, das bei 35.000 Kilometer aufhört. Da würde natürlich der untere Teil des Seils mit seinem Gewicht den oberen Teil nach unten ziehen. Das hängt ja einfach zusammen.
Natürlich, das fällt dann einfach runter. Das bleibt ja nicht einfach so. Das heißt, man muss genauso viel Masse noch mal auf der anderen Seite haben, damit da so ein Gleichgewicht ist.
Das heißt, es ist sogar so, dass der Punkt am geostationären Punkt, da bei 35.000 km, 36.000 km sind es fast, da herrscht die größte Spannung. Und das führte zu einer weiteren Idee von einem Kollegen James Pearson. Ich weiß nicht, ob man den auf Wiki findet, aber auf jeden Fall in der wissenschaftlichen Literatur. Der kam auf die Idee, wir machen das Seil einfach da dicker, wo die Spannung am höchsten ist. Und da dünner, wo sie nicht so hoch ist, um zu erreichen, dass nicht so viel Gewicht unten dranhängt. Und da kommt darauf, er könnte theoretisch diese Seile mit jedem Material bauen. Nur ist die Gesamtmasse der Materialien sehr unterschiedlich. Und für Stahl zum Beispiel, ich hab's mal ausgerechnet, um...
Also wo wär es jetzt dicker?
Am geostationären Punkt.
Und es würde sich immer weiter nach verdünnen nach unten?
Ja, und nach oben. Und der unterste Schnipel von diesem Seil ist übrigens, da herrscht gar keine Kraft mehr. Man muss ihn nicht an der Erdoberfläche festmachen, im Sinne von, dass er an der Erdoberfläche zieht. Sondern...
Der hängt da einfach drüber.
Der hängt da einfach nur drüber. Und auf der anderen Seite kann es auch dünn sein wieder. Und der Pearson hat das dann auch so berechnet, er hat gesagt, wir machen gar kein Gegengewicht, sondern wir machen einfach ein Seil. Und das Gegengewicht ist dann die Oberhälfte vom Seil. Und das hat einen sehr interessanten Vorteil, auf den ich bestimmt nochmal zurückkomme. Das bedeutet, dass das ganze Seil 144.000 km lang wird. Vor der Länge braucht man keine Angst zu haben, weil Seile kann man unendlich lang machen. Angst haben muss man vor der Spannung, die auf dem Seil ist. Und die ist unabhängig davon, ob ich da ein Gegengewicht dran hab oder einfach das Seil fortsetzen will. Und diese Spannung ist aber brutal hoch.
Warum ist das jetzt 144.000? Man würde ja erwarten, dass das Gegengewicht oben genauso lang ist wie nach unten.
Das liegt daran, dass die Erdschwerkraft eben nicht linear abnimmt, sondern das ist so eine Asymptote.
Oben muss man noch mal sehr viel länger sein, weil dann natürlich noch weniger Schwerkraft rumzuppelt. Also 144.000 Kilometer.
Ja, das ist so ein Drittel zum Mond. Das ist so ein Drittel von der Strecke zum Mond ungefähr.
Das ist schon was. Das muss man vor allem erst mal reinkriegen in so einen Satelliten.
Ja, da gibt es dann die Frage des Aufbaus. Man würde dann erstmal ein Pilotkabel hochbringen, das sehr dünn ist, also dann auch unter Umständen nur eine Tonne tragen kann. Und dann würde man sukzessive an diesen Pilotseil weitere Seilstücke hochziehen, die dann montiert werden.
Jetzt müssen wir ja nochmal zu der eigentlichen Vision kommen, weil wir haben schon viel über Seile im Weltall gesprochen. Die Idee ist eigentlich, warum spannt man nicht einfach ein Seil ins Weltall? Und jetzt haben wir schon ausgerechnet, 144.000 Kilometer müsste es lang sein, damit es dann an dem entscheidenden Punkt, nämlich genau da, wo sich Rotationen und Schwerkraft so aufheben, dass man eben geostationär so vor sich hin schwebt und eigentlich so den optimalen Punkt hat, um von dort aus irgendwo anders hin zu marschieren. Dieses lange Seil würde man gerne spannen, weil man ja dann daran hochklettern könnte. Einen Fahrstuhl dran tackert.
Richtig, eine Kabine mit Rollen dran.
Im Prinzip könnte man aber auch selber einfach anfangen, da hoch zu klettern. Man müsste dann schon immer noch so gegen seine eigene Schwerkraft, wie man das eben so kennt, von einem Seil anarbeiten. Aber umso höher man kommt, umso weniger ist ja auch zu leisten. Also wird das sozusagen immer leichter, abgesehen davon, dass das Atmen so ein bisschen knifflig wird und die Strahlung ist ja dann auch irgendwann noch mal ein Thema. Aber von der Grundidee her könnte man dann einfach nur noch mit der Überwindung der, da muss man sozusagen nur noch seine eigene Netto, sein eigenes Nettogewicht überwinden und man hat nicht mehr dieses Problem, von dem du anfangs gesprochen hast, dass man auch unglaublich viel sonstigen Kram mitnehmen muss am Anfang, um hochzukommen. Vielleicht noch so ein Stullenpaket wäre vielleicht ganz gut.
Richtig. Und ein bisschen Luft nimmt man auch noch mit, aber man braucht keinen Treibstoff. Die Energie kann man anders aufbringen?
Also ich hab natürlich, klar, wenn ich da jetzt hochkletter, dann brauch ich natürlich schon auch Energie für meinen, genau, Schnitzel. Genau, oder irgendwelche Weltraumtabletten.
Richtig, die dir Energie geben, wenn du da ziehst. Natürlich, wenn man da eine Kabine dranhängt, dann nimmt man Elektromotor und treibt den mit Strom an und den Strom kriegt man, indem man die Energie überträgt an die Kabine. Da gibt es verschiedene Technologien. Im Moment, das, was am meisten in Betracht gezogen wird, ist eine Übertragung mit Mikrowellen. Auf der Erdoberfläche hat man Mikrowellensender, zum Beispiel ein paar Windkraftanlagen unten, die erzeugen Strom, setzen das Mikrowellen um und die Mikrowellen funken das an den Empfänger. Der Empfänger setzt oben an der Kabine wieder den Strom um und füttert damit die Elektromotoren.
Ja, Funkstrom.
Ja, Funkstrom im Prinzip. Das gibt es heute schon, das wird schon eingesetzt.
Mein Laptop hat das noch nicht. Das beklage ich auch schon seit längerer Zeit.
Das prangere ich auch total an.
Also im Prinzip so Induktionen über weite Strecken. Wie so ein riesiger Induktionsherd mit eigener Windkraftanlage getrieben. Ja, Induktionen sind ein wichtiges Beispiel wegen der Wärme. Aber es geht darum, überhaupt die Energie zu übertragen. Man muss sie dann auch nicht mitnehmen. Man strahlt das sozusagen hoch, empfängt es dort, setzt es da wieder in Leistung um und damit zieht sich dann der Fahrstuhl, diese Kabine, an diesen Seil hoch mit irgendwelchen Rollen oder Klemmen oder was auch immer. Das Problem ist ja gelöst, wie man sich an deinem Seil hochzieht. Das klingt aber schon jetzt immer noch ein bisschen nach Science Fiction.
Ja, das liegt natürlich daran, dass viele Dinge nach Science Fiction sich anhören, bis man sie dann anfängt zu bauen. Ein berühmter Science Fiction Autor und Weltraumingenieur, nämlich Arthur C. Clark, der hat auch eine Science Fiction Geschichte über den Elevator geschrieben. Die heißt The Fountains of Paradise. Jetzt müsste ich den deutschen Titel erst überlegen, weiß ich jetzt. Er ist aber auch Ingenieur.
Fahrstuhl zu den Sternen.
Fahrstuhl zu den Sternen. Er hat wirklich drüber nachgedacht. Er wurde dann mal auf so einem Kongress gefragt in München. Lieber Herr Clark, wann haben wir denn unseren Weltraumfahrstuhl? Sie haben den ja jetzt schon seit Längerem propagiert. Und da hat er gesagt, wir haben den Weltraumfahrstuhl zehn Jahre, nachdem alle aufgehört haben zu lachen.
Ich muss jetzt ein sehr ernstes Gesicht machen.
Richtig, es ist tatsächlich so. Also Dinge hören sich nach Science Fiction an, solange bis man wirklich konkret anfängt, an den Problemen zu arbeiten.
Ja, genau, so war das ja bisher auch schon immer.
Ja, also sicherlich Satellitennavigation. Wenn man in den 50er Jahren jemand gesagt hätte, ich kann mit hier so einem Mobiltelefon meine Position auf der Erdoberfläche auf fünf Meter genau bestimmen, dann hätte jemand gesagt, du hast einen totalen Vogel.
Ja, und an der Stelle ist glaube ich auch Science Fiction dann wiederum ein interessanter Motor, weil man da so ein bisschen vom Lachen ins Staunen kommt und vom Staunen so ein bisschen auch ins Wollen und dann ist man wahrscheinlich auch schon auf dem richtigen Weg.
Da haben wir so ein bisschen kulturelles Handicap in Europa und gerade in Deutschland. Unser doch sehr fruchtbares Skeptizismus, der immer wieder dazu führt, dass wir Dinge neu überlegen und erstmal nicht glauben, was eigentlich erstmal sehr positiv ist, sorgt aber dafür, dass wir dieses Staunen nie ganz schaffen, umzusetzen in echte Projekte. Das ist ein bisschen schad, gerade beim Weltraumfahrstuhl. Ich denke, da gibt es Potenzial.
Jetzt sind wir ja im Prinzip so bei den Visionären. Wir haben Clark, der das schon mal so als Vision in den Raum produziert hat. Wir hatten den Zirkowski, der das dann mal ausgerechnet hat und überhaupt erstmal festgestellt hat, ja, könnte was dran sein. Clark war aber dann sozusagen nach ihm. Dann den Artso Tarnow, der dann mal ein bisschen nachgerechnet hat, was man eigentlich nun wirklich tun müsste und wo die Probleme sind. Und da ist es dann erstmal geblieben bei dieser Idee, weil alle so mit Lachen beschäftigt waren, dass sie sich gar nicht getraut haben, das irgendwie weiter zu denken. Und weil es auch in gewisser Hinsicht nicht absehbar war. Weil solange man, glaube ich, noch über Seil und Stahlseil nachdenkt und eben diese Abrissproblematik hat und einfach das Material, mit dem sich so etwas realisieren ließe, so überhaupt noch gar nicht auf eine sichtbare Weite wähnt, war das dann sozusagen überhaupt nichts, worüber überhaupt jemand nachgedacht hat.
Das war da eine Zeit lang nur eine Übung für Leute, die sich mit theoretischer Mechanik auseinandersetzen, also für Studenten. Da konnte man mal eine Diplomarbeit drüber schreiben, über die Schwingungsmoden von so einem Elevator. Bis dann tatsächlich, es gab ja dann auch Materialien, die ein bisschen stärker waren, wie Kohlefaser, die war dann besser als Stahl geeignet, aber reicht nicht. Also Kohlefaser ist um Faktor 10 zu schwach. Also man braucht ein Material, das 10-mal reißfester ist als Kohlefaser beim gleichen Gewicht, wenn man das ausrechnet.
Und Kohlefaser war zumindest lange Zeit so mit das reißfesteste überhaupt, oder?
Heute auch nur um kleine Prozentbeträge übertroffen von Dingen wie Kevlar und Dyneema, diese kommerziellen Verbundwerkstoffe. Die sind einfach nur 10-20 Prozent stärker als Kohlefaser. Was aber dann passierte, natürlich in 80er Jahren, war die Entdeckung der Buckminster Fullerene, da gab es ja auch einen schönen Nobelpreis für, und die Entdeckung, dass man aus der Kohlenstoff- Diamantbindung, ja der Kohlenstoff geht ja in verschiedene Arten der Bindung ein und die Diamantbindung ist eine der stärksten molekularen Verbindungen, die es überhaupt gibt, dass es die auch makroskopischen gibt. Also man kriegt nicht nur Moleküle, sondern Objekte, die wirklich schon makroskopisch auch zu sichtbar sind, die aus praktisch einem einzigen Kohlenstoffstrang bestehen.
Nö, nun auch Metall mitmarschieren zu können. Also du beziehst dich erstmal auf Buckminster Fuller, der mit dem Dom, der heute auch für so hübsche Zelte sorgt, dass man quasi aus solchen Fünfecken und ich glaube bisweilen auch einige Sechsecke mit eingearbeitet diese schönen großen Zeltkonstruktionen machen, die so selbst tragen sind.
Richtig.
Der Buckminster Dom oder Fuller Dom, ich weiß gar nicht genau, was das heißt. Und die Erfindung, die Entdeckung der Fullerene ist jetzt quasi auf Atom- also auf Molekülebene, dass es Moleküle gibt oder dass man sie machen kann?
Das gibt es. Die gibt es ganz natürlich im Rauch. Wenn man Ruß produziert, dann sind immer Fullerene drin. Man hat die nur entdeckt. Die gibt es auf natürlicher Atomweise. Das ist erstmal ein C60-Molekül, also ein Molekül, das aus 60 Kohlenstoffatomen besteht, die eben über diese Diamantbindung miteinander verbunden sind.
Und das ist genauso eine Fünfeckkonstruktion wie der Dom von Bankminster Fuller.
Richtig.
Das heißt, man hat sozusagen einfach etwas entdeckt, was rein zufällig genau so diese Struktur hatte und man wusste sozusagen...
So ganz zufällig ist das natürlich nicht. Also natürlich bilden sich Moleküle gemäß gewisser Regeln und eine davon ist natürlich die Minimierung der Bindungsenergie. Und dieses geometrische Konstrukt dieses Doms stellt ein energetisches Minimum dar, wie sich so ein Molekül bilden kann. Deswegen kommen die auch natürlich sehr häufig vor.
Weil es sozusagen einfach so eine Optimierung ist, so ist man dann auch leicht oder worauf hat das Auswirkungen auf Festigkeit, Gewicht?
Also der eine Aspekt ist natürlich die Festigkeit, dadurch dass es nicht nur physisch verbunden ist, sondern ein richtiges Molekül ist. Die meisten Materialien, die wir so kennen, sind ja gar keine durchgehenden Moleküle. Jetzt hier so zum Beispiel ein Faden in meiner Hose, der besteht aus einem verdrillten Baumwoll und die Baumwolle selber sind mikroskopische Fasern, die aber nur aneinander lagern. Die sich verhaken. Genau, die physikalisch zusammenhängen, aber nicht chemisch miteinander verbunden sind. Deswegen kann ich die relativ einfach auseinanderziehen. Bei diesen aus den Backminster-Folarenen abgeleiteten makroskopischen Molekülen, man nennt die dann Nanoröhrchen, wenn man die länger macht, ist das nicht so. Die sind wirklich ein durchgehendes Molekül mit sehr starken interatomaren Kräften. Das heißt, zwischen den Atomen in diesem Riesenmolekül herrschen richtige, starke Kräfte. Man kann die nicht auseinanderziehen. Also man kann die schon auseinanderziehen, ab einer gewissen Grenze. Aber diese Grenze liegt ungefähr bei einem Faktor 50 bis 100 so stark wie eine Kohlefaser.
Also das, was man so bisher als das festeste entdeckt zu haben schien, das wird jetzt übertroffen von einer Struktur, die schon auf Molekülebene so optimal zusammengesteckt ist, dass eben diese Festigkeit erreicht wird bei gleichzeitiger, ja, also auch bei Minimalismus. Das heißt, es kommt mit relativ wenig Gewicht daher und in gewisser Hinsicht bedingt sich das auch. Also weil das eben so optimal tariert ist, entsteht das eine auch durch das andere. Dadurch, dass es so leicht ist, ist es dann auch relativ reißfest.
Richtig. Diese Nano-Röhrchen, die sind hauptsächlich hol. Die bestehen hauptsächlich aus Vakuum.
Aber die Nano-Röhrchen sind jetzt sozusagen die eigentliche Erfindung und Neuschaffung auf Basis dieser Entdeckung, dass man solche Fullerene auch tatsächlich in der Natur auch schon gefunden hat.
Dachte man anfangs, dass man die nur künstlich erzeugen kann. Mittlerweile weiß man, dass die auch natürlich im normalen Ruß vorkommen. Also wenn ich hier eine Kerze nehme, die ein bisschen rußig verbrennt und lege das, was nachher rauskommt, unter ein Mikroskop, ein sehr hochauflösendes Mikroskop, da wird man schon per Zufall einige Nanoröhrchen drin finden. Die sind nicht sehr lang, die sind dann so ein paar Mikrometer lang. Man kann aber natürlich die Bedingungen im Labor dann so verändern, dass man die noch länger machen kann. Die Grenze heutzutage für die Länge von so einem Nanoröhrchen liegt bei typischerweise zwei Millimeter.
Also dieses normale Fulleren ist ja mehr wie ein Fußball, eine Fußballgitterstruktur, also mehr so kreisförmig in sich abgeschlossen. Und das Nanoröhrchen ist ja so, wenn man den Fußball in die Unendlichkeit aufklappt und quasi nur so eine Außenwand hat aus dieser selben Struktur.
Wie kann man es schön visualisieren? Wenn man die beiden mit dem Fußball in der Mitte auseinanderhackt, da hat man zwei Hälften und dazwischen wickelt man einen Zylinder aus dem selben Material. Das ist genauso.
Sieht das einfach in die Länge.
Genau, man zieht das einfach in die Länge mit mehr Atomen, die dazwischen liegen. Und dann kriegt man so eine Röhre.
Eine Röhre aus so 5er Patches.
5er und 6er Patches sind das immer abwechselnd. Diamantbindung halt. Das ist die selbe Bindung, die Kohlenstoff im Diamant annimmt. Mit dem Unterschied, dass im Diamanten ist es eine dreidimensionale Struktur, bildet sich ein ganzer Kristall. Und in dieser Bindung ist es eine Ebene. Es gibt auch ein neues Material, das erst jetzt im Millennium entdeckt wurde. Es nennt sich Graphen. Das ist einfach so eine Platte, bestehend aus dieser zweidimensionalen Struktur.
Das aber jetzt nicht natürlich, sondern das ist wirklich hergestellt.
Das muss man unter kontrollierten Bedingungen herstellen.
Das ist ja auch ein recht heißer Stoff, wo gerade alle so ein bisschen mit den Augen rollen. Mit Batteriefähigkeiten und so weiter. Man kann sagen, das Fünfeck, da lauert die Zukunft sozusagen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall für den Kohlenstoff. Weil der Kohlenstoff natürlich durch seine Elektronenkonfiguration, der hat vier freie Valenzelektronen. Das hängt damit zusammen, wenn man mal in ein Periodensystem schaut, wo der steht und so weiter. Das sind Atomphysikgrundlagen, die dahinterstecken. Da ist diese Fünfeckkonfiguration extrem stabil. Was man jetzt in den 90er Jahren erreicht hat, man hat diese Kohlenstoffnano-Röhrchen gehabt. Wenn die so ein paar Millimeter lang sind, kann man ja schon mal mit so einem Mikroapparat mal dran ziehen und mal gucken, wann das Ding reißt. Da hat man tatsächlich festgestellt, dass sie in Faktor 50 bis 100 reißfester sind bei gleichem Gewicht wie eine normale Kohlefaser. Und das Dumme ist...
Und leichter ist es auch?
Nee, genauso leicht. Weil Kohlefaser ist auch ziemlich fluffig. Aber Kohlefaser ist ja ein Verbundwerkstoff, das ist hauptsächlich Grafit- und Amorphokohlenstoff, der verbunden ist mit so einem Harz. Und da sind auch nur die physikalischen Kräfte zwischen diesen Grafit-Partikeln und dem Amorphokohlenstoff und dem Harz, die das zusammenhalten. Und in den Nanoröhrchen ist es tatsächlich eine chemische Verbindung, molekulare Verbindung, die das zusammenhält. Deswegen ist das eben umso viel reißfester. Der Trick ist jetzt das Problem, oder na gut, dann hat man eben angefangen zu rechnen. Hat man gesagt, wenn wir jetzt mal so Nanoröhrchen nehmen würden, können wir damit einen Elevator bauen, einen Space Elevator. Und dann war die Antwort, ja, können wir.
Das ist jetzt quasi die Verheißung. Auf einmal hat man einen Stoff gefunden, der genau die Bedingungen mit sich bringt. Weil der ist ja auch recht klein dann, also ist sozusagen auch von benötigtem Volumen her sehr überschaubar. Und Reißfestigkeit ist gegeben. Und ja, 50 bis Faktor, wie war das bei der Kohlefaser? Fehlte Faktor 10, wenn ich das so mal richtig erinnere. Und jetzt ist man bei Faktor 50 bis 100. Sprich, das hält.
Das hält.
Also wenn man sich jetzt vorstellt, dass man, müsste man dann immer noch diesen Kegel bauen oder?
Ja, man müsste immer noch so einen Kegel bauen. Der wäre allerdings sehr wenig ausgeprägt. Wenn man einen Faktor, jetzt muss ich kurz überlegen, Faktor 10 erreicht in der Festigkeit, dann ist das Verhältnis vom dicksten Punkt zum dünnsten Punkt ungefähr 4 zu 1. Das heißt, wenn ich hier unten mit einem Millimeter anfange, bräuchte er nur 4 Millimeter. Also es ist kaum belanglos. Jetzt gibt es aber immer noch ein Problem. Wer aufgepasst hat, hat natürlich mitgekriegt, dass 2 Millimeter nicht 144.000 Kilometer sind. Da müsste man schon ein bisschen länger strecken. Man kriegt die Dinger tatsächlich nicht sehr viel länger erst mal im Labor. Weil die entstehen aus einem Prozess, nennt sich chemische Dampfablagerung. Ich kenne nur das englische Wort. Chemical Vapor Deposition, also chemische Bedampfung. Man hat so einen Kohlenstoffdampf, den erzeugt man in einem Reaktor mit Methan. Hitzt das auf 900 Grad auf. Dadurch distoziert das Methan. Methan besteht aus Kohlenstoffwasserstoff. Wasserstoff flitzt in der Gegend rum. Kohlenstoff bleibt in der Dampfphase übrig. Und der schlägt sich an Katalysatoren ab. Katalysatoren sind typischerweise Nickelpartikel. Nanometergroße Nickelpartikel. Und an denen wächst so ein Nano-Röhrchen. Auf natürliche Art und Weise. Wie so ein Strumpf sieht das aus. Das kann man auch im Elektronenmikroskop visualisieren.
Das dockt da einfach dann an.
Das dockt da an, genau. Weil von selbst können die nicht zusammen. Das hängt mit der Chemie zusammen. Da kann man bei Gelegenheit drüber reden. Sondern nur in diesem Partikel geht das und da wächst da so ein Strumpf raus. Das Dumme ist, dieser Nickelpartikel, der erodiert, der wird selber durch diesen Prozess ein Stückchen weggerissen. Der wird verschließen. Der ist dann irgendwann mal nach typischer Weise so, eine Minute ist dieser Prozess beendet. Da das ein paar Mikrometer wächst pro Sekunde, hat man dann eben nur so ein paar hundert Mikrometer oder vielleicht mal ein tausend Mikrometer zusammen. Das ist ein Millimeter.
Also müsste man einen Weg finden, wie man dann noch mehr Nickel dazu bringt?
Das wäre eine Möglichkeit, aber es gibt seit ungefähr fünf Jahren andere Möglichkeiten. Man kann das Zeug tatsächlich verspinnen. Verspinnen hat den Vorteil, ich kann aus den Dingern tatsächlich ein unendlich langes Kabel machen. Da gibt es an der Rice University in Texas eine Gruppe, die macht das regelmäßig. Die haben schon große Trommeln, da können die unendlich lange Kabel mit diesen Dingern machen. Nachteil beim Verspinnen ist natürlich, wir sind wieder zurück bei den mechanischen Verschlingungen.
Man hat nicht mehr dieselbe Reißfestigkeit.
Man verliert die Reißfestigkeit. Man ist wieder ungefähr bei derselben Größenordnung wie Kohlefaser. Und jetzt ist es aber so, wir sind gerade an dem Punkt angelangt, wo wir eigentlich was brauchen wir, um das Seil zu machen. Wir müssen diese Fasern lang genug machen, die wir dann verspinnen, dass diese physikalische Verschlingung der einzelnen Fasern stärker wird, weil die wächst natürlich mit der Länge der einzelnen Faser, je mehr Oberfläche ich aneinander lagern kann, umso schwieriger ist es, die zwei auseinander zu reißen. Es ist schwieriger, zwei einzelne Fasern auseinander zu reißen, als eine zu zerrupfen. Weil diese eine zu zerrupfen wissen wir, ist sehr schwer zu erreichen wegen dieser starken molekularen Kräfte. Und wenn man es ausrechnet, kommt man drauf, dass man so ein paar Zentimeter, vielleicht zehn Zentimeter lange Fasern braucht.
Wenn man dann anfängt zu verschlingen, dann wird es stark genug. Also nicht der Faktor 50 und 100 von den theoretischen reinen Nanoröhren, aber zumindest mehr als, sodass man dann diesen interessanten Faktor 10 hinter sich lässt. Und dann hält es auch.
Das hält. Und dafür braucht man eigentlich nur, Anführungszeichen oben, Nanoröhrchen, die 10 cm lang sind. Mittlerweile, es gibt immer mal wieder Veröffentlichungen. Vor ein paar Jahren hat mal einer berichtet von 2-3 cm. Eine Gruppe aus Peking hatte auch schon mal 18 cm. Das Dove daran ist, dass im Moment von den Leuten, die diese langen Nanoröhrchen machen, keiner über den Elevator nachdenkt. Die sind im Moment eher aus auf die elektrischen Eigenschaften von diesen Nanoröhrchen. Deswegen gibt es in die Richtung keine Bewegung. Aber ich bin davon überzeugt, dass wir jetzt an dem Punkt angelangt sind, wo wir dieses Kabel konstruieren könnten, wenn wir aufhören zu lachen.
Ich bin ganz ernst jetzt. So, das heißt, okay, es gibt sicherlich noch ein paar Probleme zu lösen, aber man kann das jetzt eigentlich so denken, es ist zumindest absehbar, dass man so ein langes Seil macht. Das ist ja jetzt recht dünn, aber bei den 144.000 Kilometern würde es schon noch bleiben. Wenn man das jetzt aufwickelt, das ist ja auch nochmal so eine Problematik, weil man kann es ja nicht in der vollen Länge hochbringen und die Idee ist aber immer noch von oben nach unten lassen. Wie viel Masse hätte denn dieses Seil? Dieses dünne Seil?
Man bräuchte um eine Kabine mit einer Tonne Nutzlastkabine, also eine 1 Tonne Nutzlastkabine, alles drum und dran, hochzuziehen, bräuchte man ein Kabel mit einer Masse von 30 Tonnen. Und das kann man mit einer Rakete schon starten. Das hat natürlich dann unten eine Dicke von Submillimeter, auch oben, das wird nicht viel dicker. Das ist halt ein sehr reißfestes Material. Keine Ahnung, das wird dann 200 Mikrometer dick sein. Gerade so wie ein Haar, menschliches Haar.
Und da kann man eine Kabine mit einer Tonne dranhängen.
Das ist das verrückte an dem Material. Das ist so reißfest. Krass. Kannst du hier schön, keine Ahnung, VW Golf dranhängen, an einem Haar. Das ist das Erstaunliche an dem Material. Und dann, das wickelt man alle 144.000 Kilometer auf und spult das dann oben ab. Da muss man natürlich so, ich würde sagen, zwei, drei Raketenstarts wird man brauchen, um das da hinzubringen. Muss man dann montieren, da muss zusammen docken. Das wird nicht einfach sein, aber es ist machbar. Heute die ISS zum Beispiel wiegt 450 Tonnen. Die wurde auch nicht an einem Stück gestartet.
Aber das Seil müsste man ja dann da oben zusammenfädeln quasi.
Naja, das Seil würde ich vielleicht schon als ein Stück starten.
Obwohl es 30 Tonnen hat.
Das geht, aber unsere Ariane kann zum Beispiel 20 Tonnen starten. Die amerikanischen, zum Beispiel dieses SLS wird entwickelt, das startet 2017 zum ersten Mal. Der soll eine Nutzlastkapazität von 70 Tonnen haben. Man kommt da schon in die Ecke, dass man es......
kriegt man hoch. Also erst mal ein Kabel hoch, also erst mal ein Ort hoch, dann ein Kabel rein und dann den Rest. Dann baut man das irgendwie zusammen robotisch. Dann wird es abgelassen. Man lässt es dann quasi in beide Richtungen gleichzeitig.
Das geht gleich schnell. Das hat man auch schon mal ausprobiert, wieso man so einen Kabel ausspult.
Man bräuchte auch nicht ein Kabel, sondern es sind eigentlich zwei. Weil die müssen ja an der Stelle nicht verbunden sein.
Richtig. Also praktisch das obere und das untere Ende lässt man gleichzeitig raus. Und der Satellit verbleibt auf dem Schwerpunkt. So geht das dann. Und das spult sich auch von alleine raus. Man braucht nur eine Bremse. Weil die Erdgravitation...
Ach so, das fällt ja quasi runter.
Die Erdgravitation zieht dann auf der einen Seite und die Erdzentrifugalkraft auf der anderen Seite. Wenn man das erstmal so, keine Ahnung, ein, zwei Kilometer muss man das rausschießen mit so einem kleinen Düstchen, keine Ahnung, das hat man auch schon mal getestet. Mit dem Space Shuttle gab es mal eine Mission in den 90er Jahren, die hieß TSS. TSS 1R zum Beispiel war die letzte. Da hat man mal so ein 30 Kilometer langes Kabel. Und wenn die so ein, zwei Kilometer draußen sind, dann ziehen die sich quasi von alleine raus. Da muss man dann bremsen, damit es nicht zu schnell geht. Das sind alles Technologien, die schon existieren.
Das heißt jetzt, um nochmal ein bisschen zusammenzufassen, man hatte, wie gesagt, die Erdgravitation, das war schon ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen die Vision, dann hat man viel darüber nachgedacht, was man eigentlich bräuchte. Festgestellt, das gibt es alles gar nicht. Dann gab es ein paar neue Entdeckungen, vor allem diese Fullerene und daraus ableitend dann eben diese Nanoröhrchen. Mit ein bisschen Forschung hinterher, dass es jetzt zumindest absehbar, wenn auch noch nicht machbar ist, dass man im Prinzip davon ausgehen kann, dass es irgendwann möglich ist, das benötigte Seil tatsächlich zu bauen. Was nicht nur in der Lage ist, sich selbst zu tragen, sondern darüber hinaus auch noch einen Nutzlast nach oben mitführen könnte, die man dann mit so einer Mikrowellenkanone von unten mit Energie ausstattet und dann fährt da einfach so ein Fahrstuhl hoch und ist dann auf einmal 36.000 Kilometer. 35 oder 36?
Es sind knapp 35.890.
Also okay, fast 36. Okay, deswegen dachte ich auch, dass die geostationären Satelliten noch ein bisschen höher sind, aber das ist natürlich Quatsch, weil das ist natürlich der Ort. Wie auch immer. Dann hat man da oben sozusagen seinen Ort. Und was kann man denn jetzt damit machen? Also ich meine, der hat jetzt so diesen 144.000 Kilometer langen Schwanz. Das schwappt fast bis zum Mond. Das ist ja auch wirklich eine aberwitzige Konstruktion. Was kann man denn jetzt damit tun?
Alles. Damit kann man echt eine Menge Probleme lösen, die wir heute haben. Was denn so? Energie. Also der Energiekonsum auf der Erde wächst fleißig vor sich hin. 10 hoch 26 Watt verbrauchen wir so im Moment. 10 hoch 26 Watt-Sekunden in einem Jahr ist der Weltenergiebedarf steigend. Und im Moment haben wir ja eine riesen Diskussion, wie kann man am besten Energie produzieren? Und auch die Kosten steigen immer weiter. Wir haben aber eine riesen Energiequelle. Das ist nämlich die Sonne. Auf der Erdoberfläche, die mit Photovoltaik einzufangen, hat es ein paar Probleme. Nämlich, erstmal scheint die Sonne nicht immer. Schieben sich auch manchmal die Wolken davor. Es ist nicht nur die Nacht, die uns da Probleme macht. Und zum anderen verbraucht man auch eine Menge Fläche, wo man eigentlich gerne Nahrung anbauen würde für Photovoltaik. Und das ist natürlich bei der Ernährungslage auch keine gute Wahl. Wenn ich diese ganze Photovoltaik im Weltraum machen kann, habe ich zwei Vorteile. Ich verbrauche keine Erdoberfläche. Ich kann also nach wie vor meinen Reis anbauen. Und ich habe 24 Stunden, 7 Tage die Woche, 365 Tage im Jahr Sonne. Und zwar nicht nur einfach schräg einfallende Sonne, sondern direkt drauf. Das sind 1,3 Kilowatt pro Quadratmeter. Und genau wie ich die Energie für diese Kabine von unten nach oben kriege, kriege ich natürlich auch im Weltraum gewonnene Energie von oben nach unten. Die Idee ist nicht so besonders neu, nennt sich Space-Based Solar Power. Das wurde schon in den 90ern mal diskutiert, wenn man das vom Satelliten aus macht und man kommt drauf, dass man eigentlich ein Kraftwerk bräuchte, das so ein paar zigtausend Tonnen wiegt, damit sich das lohnt. Sowas kann man mit Raketen nicht starten. Das ist einfach, wenn man es ausrechnet. Die Kosten davon sind so immens, dass man das vergessen kann. Mit einem Weltraumfahrstuhl ist die Gleichung ganz andere. Da kommt das nämlich hin. Da kann man plötzlich so ein Ding starten mit mehreren zigtausend Tonnen und muss es natürlich dann im Erdorbit montieren und die Energie hier runterholen. Da hätten wir alle Energieprobleme, die wir uns je ausdenken könnten, gelöst. Das ist schon mal ein ganz großer Punkt. Und das andere ist, wir werden dann plötzlich verbunden mit dem...
Also, nur noch mal klarzumachen. Es geht nicht darum, jetzt irgendwie die Energie an dem Seil runterzulassen, sondern das Problem ist immer nur, wie kriegt man so viel Shit da überhaupt hoch, um das irgendwie zu machen, weil das irgendwie mit Raketen nicht denkbar ist, weil es einfach zu lange dauern würde, zu teuer ist. Zu teuer. Und riskant ist das in gewisser Hinsicht auch noch. Und hätte man aber einfach so ein Fahrstuhl, mit dem man so... Ich weiß nicht, wie lange wäre der eigentlich unterwegs?
Kommt darauf an, wie schnell man den fahren lässt. Also, wenn du jetzt...
Ich meine, wie schnell...
Wie würde man sich das so vorstellen? Man kann sich da vorstellen... Solange man noch die ersten 30 Kilometer ist, ist man ja noch in der Erdatmosphäre, da wird man vielleicht großartig über ein paar 100 Kilometer pro Stunde nicht rausgehen wollen. Aber die 30 Kilometer sind natürlich schnell überwunden. Und danach ist man im Vakuum, da kann man eigentlich... Ja, hundertfache Schallgeschwindigkeit ist überhaupt gar kein Thema.
Hundertfache Schallgeschwindigkeit.
Das wären dann 30.000...
Hat aber schon dann auch noch so ein mechanisches Problem. Man muss ja dann immer noch an diesem Seil...
Ja, also da gibt es bestimmt interessante Aufgaben zu lösen. Aber gut, da muss man Rollen haben, die so schnell abrollen können und...
Also es könnte sein, dass man da so in ein paar Minuten oben ist.
Ja, das wäre vielleicht ein bisschen zu schnell. Ich würde sagen, ich würde ein paar Tage veranschlagen. Sagen wir mal drei, vier Tage. Das wären dann drei, vier Tage. Das sind 500.000 Sekunden. Das sind 30... Da bräuchte man so 2000 Meter pro Sekunde, wäre ein guter Wert. 2000 Meter pro Sekunde, das ist ja noch nicht mal... Das sind ja gerade mal siebenfache Schallgeschwindigkeit. Also ich hab vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben. Das ist ja nichts.
Das fahre ich täglich. Um eine Tonne hoch zu bekommen, bräuchte man ein paar Tage. Man muss auch wieder ein paar Tage warten, bis man unten ist. Man muss ja auch wieder zurück. Das heißt, man könnte vielleicht in der Kapazität von einer Tonne pro Woche denken.
Die Idee dabei ist, man hat erst mal nur eine Tonne. In diesem ersten Pilotfahrstuhl tut man Stücke vom Seil und verstärkt das Seil. So weit, bis man irgendwann mal eine 100 Tonnen Kabine dranhängen kann. Je stärker das Seil, umso mehr kann ich dranhängen. Der baut sich selber auf, der Fahrstuhl. Das ist eine der Grundideen. Da gibt es auch ein paar Ingenieurs-Probleme zu lösen. Ich kann natürlich kein ganzes Stück Seil nach oben bringen, sondern immer nur Seilfragmente, die eben nicht die 144.000 Kilometer abdecken. Das klappt aber, man kann da immer Stücke nehmen und die dann quer verriegeln alle paar Hundert oder vielleicht alle paar Tausend Kilometer. Da macht man dann so eine Querverriegelung, die die Last übertragen kann zwischen den verschiedenen Strängen des Seils. Da gibt es Lösungen für.
Das heißt, das Ding wird dann so richtig zur Autobahn ausgebaut, wenn man eigentlich nur mit einem Trampelpfad angefangen hat?
Richtig. Und dann hat man eine Kabine, die so ein paar Hundert Tonnen tragen kann. Dafür brauche ich einen Seil mit einer Masse von 30.000 Tonnen. Und dafür habe ich dann ja genau, da sind es ungefähr 330.000 Tonnen. Und wenn ich dann 100 Tonnen transportieren kann, da habe ich dann natürlich ein paar 1000 Tonnen. Das sind dann schon ein paar Starts, bis ich dieses Photovoltaikraftwerk dann im Weltraum habe. Aber innerhalb von zehn Jahren kann man das aufbauen.
Das heißt, da kann man im Prinzip auch mal mit einem Panzer irgendwie ins Weltall fahren.
Und da sind plötzlich ganz andere Größenordnungen da. Der Gedanke allein.
Abgesehen von der Energiesache, was jetzt den Nutzen betrifft, das wird schnell klar in dem Moment, wo man beliebiges Zeug da hochgefahren bekommt und das auch innerhalb relativ kurzer Zeit. Ich wollte jetzt auf diese Geschwindigkeit eigentlich nur deshalb raus, um ein bisschen auch ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, wie lange dann auf einmal die Prozesse wären, um eine Mission zu starten. Aber im Vergleich zu dem, was man heute hat, wo man wirklich über Jahrzehnte teilweise so eine Mission plan, durchführt, einmal explodieren lässt und dann nochmal macht, und dann ist man dann irgendwann mal oben mit ein paar Tonnen, könnte man jetzt hier quasi in so einem Monatszyklus Zeug abfeiern. Und hätte dann da oben wahrscheinlich so eine Art ISS, die da so mitschwebt, so eine Plattform, an der man dann immer wieder irgendwas andockt und von dem aus man andere Sachen macht. Und dann kann man ja von da aus auch Mission zu anderen Satelliten, die da rumfliegen, starten, etc.
Richtig. Und das ist eine andere Anwendung von dem Fahrstuhl ist, man ist dann tatsächlich mechanisch mit dem Weltraum verbunden. Das bedeutet zum Beispiel, ich kann ohne Raketenantrieb, wenn ich von dem Ende des Seils loslasse, bis zum Saturn fliegen. Ohne einen Tropfen Raketentreibstoff. Das liegt einfach daran, dass ich natürlich an der anderen Seite habe ich eine nach außen wirkende Kraft und auch eine sehr hohe Geschwindigkeit. Das heißt, wenn ich da loslasse, da fliege ich auf einer hyperbolischen Bahn weg von der Erde bis zum Saturn.
Also wenn man sich eine zweite Kabine vorstellt, die an dem anderen Ende dran hängt. Und dann wird man so mit 144.000 km Abstand um die Erde herumgeschleudert.
Richtig. Und dann lässt man da los, da fliegt man bis zum Saturn.
Was ist das für ein Speed, der sich daraus so ergibt?
Also wie schnell... 144 mal... Das sind 144 mal... Da muss man die Rotationsgeschwindigkeit der Erde nehmen. Also 2 Pi pro Tag.
Das befordere dich.
Ich habe keinen Computer hier. Das ist meine Maleste. Also ich denke mal, man kommt so auf ein Paar.
Also mir würde so ein gefühlter Faktor reichen, wie viel schneller das ist, als man normalerweise eine Rakete hier so beschleunigt bekommt.
Das Dumme ist, die Raketen sind normalerweise viel schneller im Erdorbit. Also du hast so ein Satellit, die ISS fliegt mit 8 km pro Sekunde. Da oben hast du vielleicht nur 4 km pro Sekunde. Die Fluchtgeschwindigkeit an der Stelle liegt aber bei... Du hast ungefähr 10 km pro Sekunde da oben. Die Fluchtgeschwindigkeit liegt aber an der Stelle ungefähr bei 3 km pro Sekunde. 4,5 km pro Sekunde. Das heißt, du bist oberhalb der Fluchtgeschwindigkeit und den Restenergie, den du hast, der macht dann dir eine unendliche Geschwindigkeit.
Also Fluchtgeschwindigkeit ist die Geschwindigkeit, die man braucht, um die Anziehungskraft der Erde hinter sich zu lassen.
Die Fluchtgeschwindigkeit in der niedrigen Erdumlaufbahn sind 11 km pro Sekunde. Und weiter draußen nimmt die natürlich ab, weil du eben weiter weg vom Zentrum der Erde bist. Das heißt, du kannst das Sonnensystem komplett erreichen. Mit Vehikeln einfach. Mit irgendwelchen Raumvehikeln ohne Antrieb kannst du da hin. Wenn du da ankommen willst, brauchst du natürlich wieder einen Raketenantrieb. Das ist ja klar. Willst du jetzt zum Saturn reinfliegen, dann musst du natürlich diesen Gravitationswall auch wieder rückwärts überwinden. Da brauchst du dann wieder. Aber um hinzufliegen, brauchst du keinen. Auf der anderen Seite kann man natürlich auch um andere Himmelskörper auch Fahrstühle bauen. Ich könnte zum Beispiel auf dem Mond auch so ein Kabel haben und könnte von dem Erdkabel zum Mondkabel fliegen ohne Raketenantrieb und könnte dann ins Mondkabel runterklettern. Das heißt, ich hätte eine mechanische Verbindung von der Erdoberfläche zur Mondoberfläche. Das geht.
Also Weltraumfahrt würde eher so ein gigantisches Frisbee-Turnier ausarten, wo man sich dann einfach die ganze Zeit nur noch so von Ast zu Ast schwingt. So ein bisschen so Weltraum-Tarzan-mäßig.
Richtig. Ist nicht so abenteuerlich wie jetzt so eine Rakete wie bei Grudgers.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, was ich mir das so vorstelle.
Vielleicht nicht ganz so mensch.
Man schwingt sich da so von Weltraumseil zu Weltraumseil. Nur mit dem Urschrei wird es natürlich etwas schwierig. Da draußen könnte man sich ja was Neues einfallen lassen. Sprich, der Space Elevator ist, sagen wir mal, eine generelle Vision für eine ganz andere Art und Weise ins All zu gelangen und dort auch weiterzugehen. Das ist ein neuer Ansatz, um diesen ganzen, auch ja sehr nützlichen und auch kritischen Bereich der geostationären Umgebung anders zu bewirtschaften. Auch so die Probleme, die wir derzeit haben mit diesem ganzen Weltraummüll und Sachen, die da noch zu entsorgen sind. Es ist so teuer da hinzukommen, um dort überhaupt irgendwas zu machen, dass eben vieles überhaupt gar nicht erst erörtert wird, weil es einfach alle Möglichkeiten sprengen würde. Auch das würde auf einmal eine ganz andere Relation geraten. Aber jetzt mal ehrlich, ein Seilspann ist doch auch irgendwie, ich meine, da kommt ein Flugzeug und fliegt da durch und das war's.
Genau. Also da sollten wir mal über die Probleme sprechen.
Auf jeden Fall.
Ich will nicht den Eindruck erwecken, dass ich der Meinung bin, Weltraumfahrstuhl wäre jetzt morgen für machbar. Also es gibt eine Menge Probleme. Flugzeug ist ein schönes Thema. Da würde man natürlich einen Sektor sperren, dass man sagt, okay, das ist ja immer eine Stelle auf der Erde. Im Moment wird drüber nachgedacht, dass man eine Stelle, die angedacht ist, ich glaube östlich von den Galapagos Inseln, am Äquator muss man das natürlich festmachen. Da würde man ein Gebiet, keine Ahnung, 100 Kilometer im Radius drum herum, einfach für den Luftraum sperren, dass da keiner lang fliegen kann. Da gibt es auch schon die Startrampen für Raketen, die sind heute auch gesperrt. Wenn da ein Start ist bei uns in Kourou, dann ist der Luftraum da gesperrt. Darf auch keiner drüber fliegen. Andere Probleme.
Aber da muss man natürlich auch nur mal für ein paar Stunden sperren. Oder vielleicht einen Tag oder so.
Aber schon fast permanent gesperrt, der Luftraum. Also gerade Cape Canaveral zum Beispiel ist jetzt permanent gesperrt. Das ist so eine Flight Restriction Zone, da darf man gar nicht mehr reinfliegen. Kein Airliner darf da reinfliegen.
Ja. Muss aber dann natürlich auch sichergestellt werden, dass da keiner reinfliegt, weil ich meine, es gibt ja auch......Kaoten. Ich will es nicht gleich in so terroristische Dimensionen vordringen, aber so, wenn einer ein bisschen doof drauf ist, dann gibt es natürlich auch viele Mittel und Wege.
Das Seil ist relativ unempfindlich. Erstmal ist es sehr schwer, es kaputt zu machen. Also ich würde jetzt sogar tippen, wenn das seine volle Ausbaustufe erreicht hat und ich fliege da mit dem Airliner gegen, da ist an dem Seil nicht viel kaputt.
Mit dem Flugzeug?
Ja.
Da geht das Seil nicht kaputt?
Nein, das schneidet durchs Flugzeug durch und dann hat man nachher zwei Teile Flugzeug, aber ein Teil Seil. Nein. Doch. Das ist sehr stabiles Zeug.
Okay, ich kriege gerade eine andere Vorstellung von Stabilität an der Stelle. Das heißt, es wäre jetzt auch gar nicht so einfach. Mit anderen Worten, so Vögel und sowas kann man jetzt einfach mal komplett sein lassen.
Ja, die sind meistens Schlau-Vögel. Wenn sie dann dumm wären, würden sie sich wahrscheinlich den Kopf einrennen.
Obwohl das Ding nur, ich meine, was wäre denn so diese Ausbaustufe, wenn das Ding jetzt so mehrfach verdickt ist, bis man da den Panzer hochfahren kann? Wie dick ist denn das dann?
Das ist dann so, keine Ahnung, 50 Zentimeter dick. Ja, und es schneidet durch wie eine Kreisregel. Selbst wenn jemand da eine Technologie entwickeln würde, jetzt irgendeine tolle Chemikalie, die diese Nano-Röhrchen besonders toll zersetzen kann oder sowas, wenn man die untersten 30 Kilometer irgendwie kaputt macht, da fallen die halt runter. Muss man Neues ranbauen. Da passiert mit dem Rest des Kabel gar nichts.
Fliegt ja nicht alles weg? Also ich meine, wenn das unten...
Nee, dann breitet sich da eine Welle aus, die nach oben geht. So eine Entlastungswelle. Und dann kommt das ganze Seil so ein bisschen in eine Radialschwingung rein, mit einer Amplitude von, keine Ahnung, 5, 6 Kilometern, das müsste ich jetzt mal ausrechnen. Aber mehr passiert dann nicht. Und dann kann man das wieder flicken.
Aber wieso treibt das denn nicht einfach nach außen? Ich meine, wenn unten was fehlt, dann ist es doch quasi zu schwer.
Ja, das sind natürlich jetzt die bahnmechanischen Feinheiten. Plötzlich ist dieser Schwerpunkt, also du hast ja ein Kabel mit 144.000 Kilometer Länge, es fehlen davon 30 Kilometer unten. Das ist also ein ganz kleines Gipfel unten weg. Der Schwerpunkt verschiebt sich um ein paar hundert Meter.
30 Kilometer ist ja auch schon sehr schwer. Da hochzukommen. Da muss man erst mal so weit hochkommen, um da überhaupt erst mal sein Unwesen zu treiben.
Da müsste Kajdan ein ziemlich gutes Budget increase kriegen.
Selbst wenn es sozusagen so ein Full-Rain-Flugzeug gäbe, was jetzt genauso standhaft ist und da einfach mal durchsägt in einer normalen Reisehöhe, die 10 Kilometer wäre dann auch nicht so dramatisch.
Das wäre nicht so dramatisch, da würde man einfach eine Besatzung hochschicken oder vielleicht von der oberen Besatzung eine runter, die das dann flickt. Also da gibt es sicherlich Tricks, die man machen kann. Flugzeuge, Gewitter sind so ein Thema. Man hat ein bisschen Glück dadurch, dass man, man muss sowieso an den Äquator und am Äquator gibt es extrem wenig Gewitter. Und die Überlegung ist natürlich, dass man versucht, den Fahrstuhl selber in dem Teil, die letzten paar Kilometer da leitend zu machen, dass es als Art Pizzabeleiter funktioniert, dass sich in der Nähe schon mal gar keine großen Ladungsunterschiede aufbauen können. Dass man da so ein Netz reinwebt oder sowas. Dann Stürme ist das gleiche Thema. Stürme kommen sehr selten vor direkt am Äquator. Es gibt da in etwas höheren Breiten, so ab 10, 20 Grad nördlich und südlicher Breite, gibt es da so eine Sturmband, wo relativ viele Stürme und Gewitter sind. Die kommen aber da relativ selten vor. Also Hurricanes und so. Man könnte auch darüber nachdenken, dass sie einfach ein Stück weit hoch zu fahren. Dass man es dann hochzieht. Das sind so verschiedene Überlegungen, die es da gibt. Ich würde denken, dass das Seil wenig beeinflusst wird durch Wind. Weil es einfach so furchtbar stabil ist Es hat eine relativ große Fläche. Natürlich ist es auch flexibel, klar. So kannst du es hinterher schlackern, kannst schon. Man würde es tatsächlich auch unten verankern. Die Verankerung sollte mobil sein. Aus verschiedenen Gründen. Die Lösung, über die im Moment nachgedacht wird, ist eine ausrangierte Ölbohrinsel. Da wird es dann verankert drin. Dann kann die unten hin und her fahren.
Die schwimmt mit?
Ja, die schwimmt mit. Die einzigen Kräfte, die tatsächlich auftreten unten, sind seitliche Kräfte. Die müsste man dann antreiben, diese fahrbare Antraßstation.
Wenn du sagst, bei Galapagos, ist es nicht so, dass man auf die Galapagos-Inseln sagt, mach mal Platz, wir müssen hier einen Weltraumbahnhof bauen. Sondern man würde es tatsächlich wirklich in der See verankern, ohne Anker sozusagen, mehr so ein Schiffchen mitfahren lassen, was immer so die aktuellen Tagesschwankungen so mitmacht.
Richtig, weil was passiert, dynamisch ist, auch wenn so eine Kabine hochfährt, die erzeugt eine Welle in diesem Seil, wie eine Schwingung auf einer Gitarrenseite. Das schwingt dann hin und her. Und diese Welle breitet sich am Lang des Seils aus und das muss man managen. Das heißt, dass sich das nicht aufschwingt. Da muss man da unten so ein gegenphasiges Schwingung draufgeben. Was man auch haben will, und das ist wieder ein anderes Problem, ist natürlich, es gibt immer noch Satelliten. Die werden ja nicht verschwinden. Und so ein Satellit, wenn der da reinkracht mit ein paar Kilometer pro Sekunde, der kann das Seil natürlich kaputt machen.
Also wenn das einer abstürzt zum Beispiel?
Ja, auf seiner normalen Umlaufbahn. Die Satelliten sind ja rauf.
Ach so, ja klar, weil die ja noch deutlich niedriger sind.
Und da kann man den Satelliten tatsächlich ausweichen. Indem man zur rechten Zeit da Schwingungen...
Ah, die Schwingungen ran macht und sozusagen einfach so vorbeischlackert, so einen ganz eleganten Körperschwung sozusagen da veranstaltet.
Ja, und da hat man diese Seilschwingung, die hat so eine Amplitude von 50 Kilometer oder so was und da kann man jedem Satelliten ausweichen. Man muss halt natürlich wissen, zu welcher Zeit, welcher Schwingungszustand des Seils gebraucht wird.
Das heißt, so Programme wie Space Situational Awareness, die Beobachtung der gesamten Weltraumlage, also einerseits natürlich der Schrottbeobachtung, andererseits auch der normalen Operation, das wäre sozusagen so ein integraler Bestandteil, um die Sicherheit dieses Seils sicherstellen zu können.
Richtig. Man muss also wissen, also die ganz kleinen Teile muss man nicht wissen. So ein ganz zentimetergroßes Objekt, das kann auch ruhig mal mit dem Seil kollidieren. Das wird unter Umständen ein Loch machen in das Seil. Das muss man dann flicken. Deswegen ist es auch wichtig, dass das Seil aus mehreren Strängen besteht. Wenn dann aus einem Satz von 2000 Strängen in der Mitte mal 20 durchbohrt werden, dass man die dann da in eine Kabine hochfährt, da geht dann eine Reparaturcrew dran und zieht die kaputten Stränge raus und zieht neue rein und verriegelt die mit den noch intakten Strängen.
Das heißt, diese ganze Verdickung ist gar nicht mal jetzt nur, um dem Teil die notwendige Transportkapazität zu verschaffen, sondern auch, um das auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise wachbar und lebensfähig zu machen. Das heißt, am Ende hat dann die Erde nicht nur Weltraumbahnhöfe, das wäre die Frage, ob man da überhaupt noch Raketen betreiben würde. Das löscht das irgendwie aus.
Der Wettbewerb ist so klar, wenn ich auf der einen Seite für 200 Euro einen Kilogramm starten kann und auf der anderen Seite für 20.000. Also baut ja heute auch keiner mehr einen 8-Bit-Prozessor. Es gibt natürlich immer Sonderanwendungen.
Aber die Kapazität ist natürlich dann auch nicht... Das ist die Frage, ob man überhaupt schnell genug neue Sachen bauen kann, wenn man sie hochkriegt.
Es wird natürlich eine Übergangsphase geben. Aber man muss ja nicht bei einem Weltraumbahn-Fahrstuhl Schluss machen.
Man kann ja fünf machen. Die können alle ganz prima co-existieren. Sie müssen aber einen gewissen Mindestabstand schon voneinander haben. Wie weit müssten die so auseinander sein? 100 Kilometer?
Es hängt davon ab, wie man sich den 100 Kilometer –weil unten diese Ankerstationen hin und her fahren können.
Die schlagern ja auch ganz deutlich. Was ist, wenn jetzt so ein Asteroid, der hergeschossen kommt?
Den kann man ausweichen.
Das wäre sozusagen genau derselbe Sport. Man muss dann halt einfach sehen, zack. Aber bisher kriegt man ja auch noch nicht alle mit. Wir hatten ja nun gerade vor ein, zwei Monaten da den Meteoritenschauer in Russland. Das Ding hat so recht keiner kommen sehen. Alle haben auf den anderen geschaut, der am gleichen Tag vorbeigeflogen ist und auf einmal holler.
Die gefährliche Ecke sind die Objekte so zwischen unterhalb von zehn Meter. Ab zehn Meter sieht man die eigentlich ganz gut. Der dann auch an der Erde vorbeigeflogen ist, den Namen habe ich jetzt vergessen. Den hat man ja vorher gesehen schon ein paar Monate.
Aber der andere halt nicht.
Genau, der war eben so drei, vier Meter im Durchmesser. Und die würden natürlich das Seil einfach zack, wenn die genau das Zentral treffen. Aber erstmal ist die Häufigkeit von diesen Dingern sehr gering. Auf der Erde schlagen pro Jahr vielleicht zehn von denen ein. Die Querschnittsfläche der Erde ist immens. Die Querschnittsfläche von dem Kabel ist zwar auch recht groß, aber nicht so groß wie die Erde.
Also die Wahrscheinlichkeit, das wird nicht so ein Objekt, das Ding trifft, ist schon sehr überschaubar.
Sehr überschaubar. Und wenn es dann doch passieren sollte, gibt es Methoden, wie man das Seil dann tatsächlich entsorgt, ohne dass es auf die Erde zurückfällt. Man kann dann weiter unten sprengen, wenn man zum Beispiel in der Mitte einen Bruch hat, vom kompletten Seil in der Mitte, dass man dann ganz unten an der Erde sprengt, dass der Mittelteil, da gibt es dann ja einen Mittelteil, dass der in der Umlaufbahn bleibt, dass man den dann aus der Umlaufbahn wieder einfangen kann und dann nur die untersten, keine Ahnung, 100 Kilometer runterfallen, die fallen dann tatsächlich auf die Erdoberfläche, würden dann in diesem Schutzradius liegen bleiben, kann man dann wieder einsammeln. Dieser Mittelteil bleibt im Orbit und der obere Teil, der haut nach außen ab. Und da gibt es dann Methoden, wie man mit so einem gebrochenen Seil umgeht. Da hat man natürlich dann Pech gehabt, und so kann man wieder von vorne anfangen. Es sei denn, man war so schlau in der Zwischenzeit, einen zweiten Fahrstuhl zu bauen. Weil wenn man erst mal einen hat, dann kann man auch einen Schwester-Fahrstuhl bauen.
Hm, klingt ja so ein bisschen wie der gordische Knoten, den man da so lösen könnte, um sozusagen die Beackerung des Weltaus auf einmal ganz anders anzugehen, als man das bisher gemacht hat.
Richtig. Durch diesen Flaschen Hals muss man durch.
Jetzt bist du ja so ein bisschen als Prophet in dieser Sache auch unterwegs. So, nicht nur hier. Du hast auch schon mal so einen kleinen Ted-Talk, glaube ich, zu dem Thema abgeworfen. Und wir finden es jetzt auch ansonsten da so in der Diskussion. Du bist aber jetzt nicht wirklich, du verstehst dich selber ja eigentlich mehr als Beobachter des Vorgangs. Gibt es denn jemanden, der dann auch wirklich da aktiv dran arbeitet?
Ja, also es gibt einige. Also auf universitärem Bereich gibt es natürlich viele, die jetzt an Materialien forschen. Das Rice University in Texas. Dann gibt es die Kollegen aus Peking, die auch an den Materialien arbeiten. Das sind Spezialisten. Aber es gibt auch das International Space Elevator Consortium. Das kann man auch mal googeln. Die koordinieren so ein bisschen die Aktivitäten. Die veranstalten zum Beispiel auch so Wettbewerbe zum Thema Wer baut das stärkste Seil? Dann haben da auch ein paar Millionen Dollar ausgeschrieben für den Sieger. Ich glaube, man muss was bauen, was doppelt oder viermal so stark ist wie Kohlefaser. Dann kriegt man da zwei Millionen oder so. Genau, Strong Tether Challenge ist das. Und dann gibt es auch jedes Jahr eine Konferenz. Space Elevator Conference ist dieses Jahr in Seattle. In Europa gibt es auch einige Aktivitäten. Letztes Jahr gab es in München eine Space Elevator Konferenz. Da war dieses Space Elevator Konsortium auch schon involviert. Man munkelt, dass die Google X-Labs auch am Space Elevator arbeiten, aber die rücken natürlich mit nichts raus. Und es gab mal vor zwei Jahren eine Pressemitteilung von einer japanischen Hochbau-Company. Die haben gesagt, wir wollen einen Elevator bauen. Ehrlich gesagt hielt ich das ein bisschen für so einen PR-Stunt. Die haben sich einfach auf das Thema draufgesetzt, um mal wieder in den Nachrichten zu sein.
Hochbau klingt ja auch so ein bisschen, als ob sie von unten nach oben gebaut wurden.
Ja, stimmt. Hatten die alte Idee wieder aufgegriffen, aber tatsächlich, denke ich, hatten die da den Elevator im Blick.
Also das von unten nach oben, das kann man vergessen, oder?
Das liegt einfach daran, dass du dann die Stützmasse erst mal unten da haust. Es gibt übrigens auch Kombinationsideen, dass man so einen langen Turm baut, von dem aus man dann so einen Parabelflug startet. Es gibt so Ideen, es gibt auch auf dem Gebiet eine Menge Scharlatanen. Also als Beobachter sieht man das auch immer wieder, dass dann Leute da einfach, um mal ein Buch zu verkaufen, sich da engagieren. Man muss ein bisschen drauf gucken. Also meine Rolle bei der Sache ist ein bisschen, wie du schon sagst, Beobachter, ich hab die Literatur mal durchgeguckt und da ich Physiker bin, kann ich so ein bisschen da die Enden verknüpfen, um da ein gesamtes Bild mir zu erzeugen. Und ich bin da eigentlich sehr skeptisch ursprünglich drangegangen, war dann überrascht, wie weit man eigentlich schon ist, gerade bei diesem Materialproblem. Und hab mich dann entschieden, das weiter im Auge zu behalten, um vielleicht auch mal der ESA zu helfen, wenn, falls, die ESA mal Interesse in die Richtung zeigt, da dann bereit zu sein und da technischen Hintergrund zu haben.
Jetzt zu dem derzeitigen Zeitpunkt ist jetzt auch für die ESA da kein unmittelbares Thema verbunden, abgesehen jetzt von so Nebenkriegsschauplätzen, wie schon erwähnt SSA zum Beispiel, beziehungsweise auch überhaupt das ganze Neudenken der Weltraumtechnik. Hat mich ja auch schon mal in Holland mit dem Advanced Concepts Team unterhalten, die ja auch mal ganz frisch sind, was so komplett neue Ideen angeht. Und klar, wenn man jetzt erstmal eine ganz andere Plattform und das im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes hätte, dann sind natürlich auch Missionen auf einmal vorstellbar, auf die glaube ich derzeit so noch auch gar keiner kommt, weil das einfach so ausgeschlossen ist. Richtig. Aber wenn man mal so in diese Richtung denkt, also ein paar Sachen hast du ja schon angesprochen, sagen wir mal das Ding würde jetzt irgendwie nächste Woche so eröffnen. Da fahren sie alle irgendwie ganz Politiker da auf dem Pazifik und schwappeln da so ein bisschen auf dieser Plattform rum und durchschneiden dann das rote Band zum Weltraum. Abgesehen davon, dass man das, was man derzeit schon tut, anders, billiger, besser, zuverlässiger, häufiger, öfter machen kann. Was wären denn sozusagen die Perspektiven, die sich jetzt ergeben? Wir hatten schon diesen Energiebereich, hatten wir schon, den vielleicht mal, ich wollte jetzt ganz konkret auf die Missionierung des Weltraums aus. Was für Missionen, die heutzutage unvorstellbar sind oder nur sehr, sehr selten mal gemacht werden können, sind denn auf einmal vorstellbar und wie würde sich das dann auch ändern können?
Ja, also ein Aspekt ist natürlich, wie du schon gesagt hast, man kann das, was man tut, einfach um ein paar Größenordnungen vergrößern. Als Beispiel würde ich mal sagen, auf der Erde haben wir heute riesige Teleskope, 8 Meter Spiegel, 20 Meter Spiegel. Das kann man ja alles mit einer Rakete gar nicht starten, weil eine Rakete rüttelt da durch, da geht jeder Spiegel kaputt. Deswegen sind unsere Weltraumteleskope erstens einigermaßen bescheiden von der Größe her, so in der Größenordnung 3,5 Meter ist der Herschelspiegel, aber auch sehr robust gebaut. Machen also Kompromisse. Man könnte sich vorstellen, so einem Elevator ein echtes Observatorium in den Weltraum zu bringen.
Also das, was man heute sozusagen nur als Bodenstation hätte, einfach mal nach oben zu fahren.
Genau, das La Silla Teleskope in Hawaii, oder die großen Teleskope, WLT in Hawaii, einfach mal ein Weltrauber legen. Das ist mal so die konservativste Annahme bei der Sache. Was natürlich auch eröffnet, ist der private Raumflug.
Also noch mal kurz, Teleskopvision find ich insofern so interessant, wenn man jetzt solche Spiegel, wie man sie auf der Erde hätte, also die müssten ja nicht genau so groß sein, aber sagen wir mal, wenn man überhaupt die Teleskop-Spiegelfläche, wie man sie derzeit im Weltall hat, ich weiß nicht, was ist der größte derzeit, der unterwegs ist?
Herschel, 3,5 Meter.
Herschel, genau. Dreieinhalb Meter, wenn man das irgendwie auf 30 Meter oder so was ausdenken könnte, das wäre eine unfassbare Verbesserung der Beobachtungsqualität im Vergleich zu heute.
Was man, man könnte auch zum Beispiel Interferometer starten mit solchen Spiegeln und die könnten zum Beispiel, wenn die weiter genug auseinander platziert werden würden, die andere Planeten in unserer Milchstraße abbilden. Wir wissen heute, es gibt ungefähr 1000 Planeten, die irgendwo in der Milchstraße verteilt sind, wo wir auch nicht wissen, ob es vielleicht Leben geben kann da drauf. Man könnte ein Teleskop bauen, das ein Bild von dem macht.
Aber derzeit kann man sie ja optisch gar nicht sehen, weil sie überstrahlt sind von ihren Sonnen und auch sonst wenig reflektieren. Und dann würde das Restlicht ausreichen, was sie reflektieren, um sie zu sehen.
Was man dann machen kann mit solchen großen Teleskopen ist, man kann Interferometrie betreiben, die Auflösung, die Vergrößerung so groß machen, dass man einfach das, also entweder kann man es sich selbst auslöschen lassen interferometrisch, das nennt sich Nulling Interferometry, das Licht von dem Stern oder man kann sogar abdecken mit einer Art Koronograph. Das geht natürlich nur, wenn die Vergrößerung groß genug ist. Heute ist es einfach so, dass ich, wenn ich ein Bild davon machen will, dann ist der Stern von seinem Planet um ein paar Mikrobogensekunden entfernt vom Winkel her, von einer Winkelauflösung und das reicht einfach. So eine hohe Auflösung habe ich nicht, um die voneinander zu trennen. Wenn ich die in meiner bildgebenden Optik voneinander trennen kann, dann kann ich auch den Stern einfach abdecken. Das ist so ein Konzept. Terrestrial Planet Finder haben die Amerikaner mal aufs Tablet gebracht. Für Forschung gibt es Unglaubliche. Man könnte Radioteleskope bauen auf dem Mond oder im freien Weltraum. Man könnte große Interferometer zur Vermessung von Gravitationswellen in den Weltraum bringen. All die Sachen wären plötzlich nicht nur möglich, sondern auch relativ einfach durchführbar. Was auch interessant ist natürlich die private Raumfahrt. Da gebe ich mir keine Illusion hin, dass heute gibt es natürlich Firmen wie SpaceX und Scales Composite, diese Spaceship-2-Leute. Die bieten dafür ein paar Hunderttausend Euro einen Parabelflug an. Das ist eigentlich keine echte Raumfahrt. Dann sind für eine private Reise in den Weltraum kaum Grenzen gesetzt.
Weil man mit dem Fahrstuhl hochfährt und dabei immer leichter wird?
Richtig. Du stehst dann im Fahrstuhl, wirst immer leichter. Ich wiege jetzt hier 85 Kilo, das ist immer weniger. Irgendwann bin ich schwerelos. Dann muss ich mich rumdrehen, muss die Füße auf die andere Seite nehmen und dann wäre ich immer wieder schwerelos.
Das ist natürlich auch für die Astronauten sehr viel sanfter, weil ja auch die Belastungen durch den Start enorm sind. Viel des Trainings, also manches zählt natürlich auf die Arbeit vor Ort, aber sehr viel ist allein nur dem Start geschuldet. Die großen Belastungen, die vielen gehen, die auf einen wirken, die auch nicht ganz folgenlos sind. Das würde ja im Prinzip auch komplett wegfallen.
Das fällt komplett weg. Auch der Wiedereintritt natürlich. Das ist ja eins der schlimmsten Teile von einer Weltraummission für Astronauten, wenn das der Wiedereintritt ist. Wenn man da so just so kommt. Ja, genau. Und das wäre dann auch weg. Eine Gefahr kommt allerdings dazu, man kann runterfallen vom Fahrstuhl. Bei einem Satelliten-Raketen-Start nach acht Minuten bin ich in der stabilen Umlaufbahn, da kann ich erstmal nicht runterfallen. Da kann ich mein Vehikel, kann ich ausschalten, brauch ich keinen Triebwerk, kein gar nichts. Wenn jetzt aus irgendeinem komischen Grund diese Kabine sich löst von dem Seil, fällt die runter. Knallt irgendwo runter, ist schlecht. Da müsste man sich die was einfallen lassen.
Also müsste man wahrscheinlich auch noch ein bisschen noch ein paar Hitzekrachen dranlassen und dann noch ein paar, ja gut, ob man da mit dem Fallschirm soweit kommt.
Oder ein Sicherungsseil, irgendwas. Keine Ahnung. Also es gibt noch ungelöste Fragen. Eine andere Sache, die wir noch nicht angesprochen haben, die auch sehr erstaunlich wäre, ist tatsächlich die Versorgung der Erde mit Rohstoffen aus dem Weltraum. Das ist ein lang diskutierter Traum. Kommt auch immer wieder in Science-Fiction-Büchern vor. Ist aber, solange wir Raketen haben, ein totales Hirn gespinst.
Ein Minusgeschäft, wo man einfach viel zu viel reinstecken müsste und ganz wenig zu bekommen.
Wenn ich ein Kilogramm von irgendeinem Material vom Mond zurück zu bekommen, kostet es ein paar Hundert Millionen Euro. Da kann das, egal wie wertvoll dieses Material ist, es wird sich nie lohnen, das vom Mond wieder zu holen.
wenn man da Platin ausgraben könnte. Oder Lithium.
Ein Kilo Platin, ich weiß gar nicht, was es im Moment kostet. Ein paar Hunderttausend vielleicht. Werden schon ein paar Millionen sein, aber nicht hunderte Millionen.
Sieht dann auch ganz anders aus auf einmal.
Richtig, da ist die Gleichung auch wieder eine andere. Beispiel seltene Erden findet man auf Astheoriden in großen Mengen. Auf der Erdoberfläche nicht so sehr. Oder auf dem Mond findet man auch seltene Erden. Und die könnte man dann relativ einfach... Das Interessante ist, wenn ich vom Fahrstuhl runterkomme, die Energie, die ich gewinne beim Runterklettern, die kann ich wieder reinstecken in das Vehikel, was hochgeht.
Das heißt, wo einer runterfährt, schiebt man damit jemand anderen auch gleich raus? Pfff, pfiffig.
Also sogar diese Restkosten kann man noch weiter senken.
Was ist denn mit diesen Deep Space Missionen, die ja nun selten genug sind? Die werden ja dann auch gleich wieder ganz anders aufgestellt, oder?
Deep Space meinst du jetzt im Sonnensystem oder sogar außerhalb?
Ja, wie Deep auch immer das Ganze jetzt so geht. Aber sagen wir mal, so eine Mission wie mit Cassini Heugens zum Titan, das hat ja nun schon einen ziemlich seltenen Heizwert, aber es war ja interessant genug da vor Ort, um da auch nochmal ein weiteres Mal vorbeizuschauen.
Ja, also da hat man natürlich genau den Punkt, dass man im Prinzip Cassini am Ende des Seils loslassen könnte. Man bräuchte null Treibstoff, um zum Saturn zu kommen. Natürlich der Einschuss im Saturn-System, der müsste dann von Cassini gemacht werden. Und da könnte man viel regelmäßiger das Sonnensystem untersuchen. Ganz klar. Das ist eine andere Größenordnung.
Wenn du sagst, zum Saturn kommen heißt, weiter reicht es nicht?
Weiter reicht es nicht ohne Antrieb. Die Bahngeschwindigkeit von dem oberen Ende des Seils ist natürlich beschränkt. Wenn ich da loslasse, dann habe ich einen Aphelion, das ist der weiteste Abstand dieser Bahn im Sonnensystem, gemessen, der ist ungefähr beim Saturn.
Und wenn man jetzt da mit Swing-By und nochmal Schwung holen...
Da kann man natürlich noch weiter.
Also das geht schon. Man kriegt dann die Energie auch noch. Aber man braucht schon immer irgendwelche Antriebe, um zumindest mal den Weg ändern zu können.
Richtig. Und andere Sachen ist natürlich, man kann dann anfangen auch... Wenn man jetzt noch wirklich in die Zukunft denkt, kann man andere Antriebe einsetzen. Dann muss man nicht immer beim chemischen Raketenantrieb bleiben.
So wie zum Beispiel bei diesem Smart-Mobil... Richtig.
Elektrische Antriebe.
Tja, wo kann man da unterschreiben?
Kann man da auch unter Petition? Nein, im Endeffekt, was es bedarf noch ist, ist der Fokus. Im Moment ist die Nano-Welt nicht darauf aus, möglichst starke Materialien zu bauen, weil es viel profitabler ist, hochreine Nanomaterialien zu bauen, dann auch mit Verbundwerkstoffen zu arbeiten. Das ist einfach woanders fokussiert im Moment. Die Weltraumagenturen haben das auch noch nicht auf dem Radar, dafür sind wir noch nicht in der richtigen Phase. Die Weltraumagenturen könnten auf den Plan treten, in dem Moment, wo wir das Material in der Hand haben. Dann können wir anfangen, dieses ganze Engineering-Problem zu lösen, mit dem Ausweichen, diesen Wellen, den mechanischen wie baue ich das auf und so weiter. Das ist eine Aufgabe für Weltraumagenturen. Jetzt müssten eigentlich die Materialforscher ran und da ist im Moment nicht der Fokus da. Es kann auch sein, dass wir morgen einen großen Artikel in der FAZ oder in der TAZ lesen. Vielleicht eher nicht.
Oder zumindest erstmal in einem wissenschaftlichen Magazin.
Eine Faser, zehnmal so stark wie Kohlefaser, wurde erfunden. Auswirkungen bisher unbekannt.
Aber im Prinzip ein Durchbruch in der Nanoröhrentechnik, der ja zumindest vorstellbar ist. Es gibt dann einen Weg hin. Könnte auf einmal eine ganze Menge in Bewegung bringen. Bis dann all diese ganzen Technologien erfunden sind und Programme abgewickelt sind, wird es so oder so noch mehrere Jahrzehnte in Anspruch nehmen.
Ich denke schon, dass man das in zehn Jahren schon packen kann.
Dass man das komplett baut, wenn man jetzt weiß, wie man das mit dem Seil hinkriegt. Und dann steht das Ding. Und dann geht es schon los. Ich habe noch eine Chance sozusagen als Weltraumtourist, trotz schlechter Physis.
Das ist ja das Tolle.
Mal mehr als 22 Sekunden Schwerelosigkeit am Stück zu erleben.
Richtig.
Das wäre natürlich dann, ich meine, nicht dass Tourismus jetzt das Wichtigste ist überhaupt, aber es wäre vor allem auch absehbar, dass eine nennenswerte Zahl von Menschen auf einmal in die Lage versetzt werden, diesen Blick von oben zu wagen.
Und da gibt es ja zwei Richtungen. Erst mal die Perspektive auf die Erde runter. Ich denke, das hätte schon für größere Bevölkerungsschichten einen sehr interessanten Effekt. Auch kulturell, dass man eine andere Perspektive kriegt. Aber auch den Blick nach außen. Dass man plötzlich, man guckt nach außen, sieht aha, Moment mal, da ist ja alles. Das steht uns ja vor der Haustür hier.
Ja, man sieht dann ja auch deutlich mehr als man bisher sieht. Auf einmal glüht ein dieses ganze Weltall in einer Intensität an, wie man sich das, glaube ich, so gar nicht so richtig vorstellen kann. Und jetzt auch hier aus meinen Gesprächen, die ich so mit angehenden und schon bewährten Astronauten auch immer wieder herausgezogen habe, ist so, dass dieser Blick von oben auf so die verletzliche Erde für einigen Sinneswandel gesorgt hat. Ich meine, Leute, die sich so intensiv damit beschäftigen, haben diesen Sinneswandel wahrscheinlich auch schon vorher im Prinzip vollzogen. Trotz alledem ist das so eine Wirkung, glaube ich, der einfach so die Verletzlichkeit dieses Planetens einfach nochmal auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise umbringt.
Ich denke, da ist auch wirklich ein Unterschied zum akademisch darüber Lesen, ja, unsere Welt ist verletzlich, und es selbst zu erfahren. Wenn man es selbst sieht und wahrnimmt, ist es ein Riesenunterschied. Und ich denke, die Raumfahrt hat uns schon in den Punkt gebracht, dass wir die Verletzlichkeit auf einem intellektuellen Level irgendwo verstanden haben. Und es ist ja auch schon viel geschehen in Richtung Nachhaltigkeit. Und der ganze Weltraumfahrstuhl ist einfach auch eine neue Dimension in Nachhaltigkeit, weil er ist nicht eine Rakete, die weggeworfen wird nachher, sondern er ist eine Infrastruktur, die existiert, die auch da, wenn ich die Kabine hochgefahren ist, dann steht er immer noch da, der Weltraumfahrstuhl, kann ich die nächste Kabine hochfahren. Also es ist eigentlich eine neue Dimension in der Nachhaltigkeit. Ich kann viele Probleme, die wir auf der Welt im Moment haben, weil wir nicht nachhaltig wirtschaften, lösen. Oder unseren Weg in die Nachhaltigkeit, wir sind ja schon auf dem Weg in die Nachhaltigkeit, noch deutlich stärker beschleunigen. Und die Hoffnung ist natürlich, dass wir schneller nachhaltig werden, als wir Dinge kaputt machen auf unserem Planeten. Und ich denke, der Fahrstuhl wäre eine Lösung für viele der Probleme, die wir haben.
Ja, das ist interessant. Seekabel haben seinerzeit mal die erste Globalisierung im Prinzip eingeleitet. Das Kabel ins All wäre dann sozusagen die nächste Stufe.
Das wäre eine schöne Analogie.
Ja, Markus, ich glaube, jetzt haben wir es ganz gut eingerahmt.
Finde ich auch.
Ja, ich weiß jetzt auch mehr als vorher. Ich hoffe, so dürfte es den, ich denke, den meisten Hörern geht es jetzt ähnlich. Ja, macht mal weiter.
Ja, also wer Lust hat, kann auch mal meinen TED-Talk angucken, da habe ich so ein bisschen mehr erklärt.
Den überdenken wir.
Ja, genau, super.
Ja, das war's. Raumzeit, Ausgabe 54. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Ich sage tschüss und bis bald.